para millones de afganos es un rayo de
esperanza un primer avión humanitario
aterrizó sobre la pista del aeropuerto
de kabul a bordo 60 toneladas de ayuda
alimentaria y médica provenientes de los
emiratos árabes unidos- un apoyo
internacional que hasta el momento
estuvo interrumpido desde la llegada al
poder de los talibanes el pasado 15 de
agosto
llamamos a todos los países incluidos
los emiratos árabes unidos- ayudamos en
los campos de la salud de la
alimentación y otros ámbitos
humanitarios porque nuestro país está en
guerra
según naciones unidas la situación es
urgente 19 millones de afganos necesitan
ayuda humanitaria y si nada cambia más
de la mitad de los menores de 5 años
sufrirán de hambre el año que viene
además múltiples factores sobre todo
económicos y climáticos podrían agravar
la situación
de
nuestros compañeros del ámbito
humanitario nos alertan que afganistán
afronta una crisis alimentaria y de
malnutrición es que la situación se
complicará a causa de la sequía que ya
afecta a un tercio del país
y han sido reanudados los vuelos de la
onu hacia el norte y el sur del país el
secretario general antonio guterres
presidirá una reunión el 13 de
septiembre para alentar a los estados
miembros a aumentar la financiación para
ayudar a la población afgana